now yesterday president biden played
farmer in illinois in a pathetic attempt
to show that he cares about the supply
chain and farming crisis
but there's something troubling
happening to farmland some 60 600 miles
southwest that deserves attention over
the past two years chinese nationals
have begun buying up tens of thousands
of acres of farmland in the state of
oklahoma
while they've been doing so in a number
of states oklahoma has become their
go-to state for these purchases so
what's china's end goal here
well according to a statement from the
oklahoma bureau of narcotics to the
ingram angle eventually these farms
typically become commercial marijuana
growing operations
they went on to note that they buy
agricultural or livestock farms then
they turn them into marijuana farms and
then they sublet those uh that business
to mexican workers
congressman frank lucas represents
oklahoma's third district where a lot of
this is happening he says his office has
received a number of uh calls concerns
from constituents voicing real worry
about foreign owner of land purchases
and how the land is then being used to
grow mayor
marijuana now he went on to tell us that
according to the bureau of narcotics
there are 8 500 medical marijuana grow
licenses in oklahoma and of those a
shocking 25 of them
are run by criminal organizations from
places like china and mexico
now the state saw the biggest drug bust
in its history this past february where
chinese nationals were among those
arrested
here are officers describing the scope
of these operations over 500 structures
on 80 acres
this is one of the nine that we serve
the search warrant on this morning this
is a pretty good sized drug trafficking
organization
it's not
the nine that we did today are all
connected and it's part of this
organization that's responsible for
moving
tons and tons of marijuana out of
oklahoma and other states
and these aren't just marijuana farms
according to senator lankford's office
constituents have mentioned these buyers
often aren't doing anything with the
land at all quote they just purchase it
and then they just have it
in other words these chinese affiliated
buyers want to devalue american farmland
in any way they can't or just hold it in
their portfolios how nice
so just how brazen is this langford
spokesperson told us that constituents
have said chinese parties have knocked
on their door to purchase their farmland
in some cases they were offered a
suitcase of cash to make the deal that
day
oklahoma bans foreign ownership of
farmland but there's a loophole that
allows foreign investors to create a
business and they then buy land for that
business
a state senate bill introduced back in
february aimed at stopping this but as
far as we can see it hasn't gone
anywhere
but given the economic and the national
security ramifications here
congress should get involved
a bill to limit purchases of
agricultural tracks by china
was working its way through the house
but apparently stalled in committee this
is absurd and it's typical washington
failing to do what needs to be done as
it spends money
that we don't have on stuff we don't
need
we're going to bring you updates on this
as we get them hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else